let's move on to a video of jake tapper
over on cnn because there's a lot of
things happening right now it's not just
about guns it's about the economy it's
about the whole thing take a look two
things sure stand out in this new poll
one the economy a top priority and two
americans disapprove of president
biden's handling of this
more than ever before yeah and those two
things together uh spell a tough
political environment for democrats the
president and his party take a look here
most important issue it's by far jake 50
of people in this poll say the economy
is the most important issue facing the
country russia ukraine ward 14
immigration at 10
everything else in single digits we
should note this poll was completed just
before that bombshell news from the
supreme court on abortion biden's
handling of that number one issue
only had a 34 percent approval rating on
the economy 66 percent disapprove and
that number there jake that's been going
down since our poll earlier this year he
was at 37 approval on the economy now
he's down to 34
and in terms of biden's policies look at
this a majority of americans in this
poll 50 55 percent say biden's policies
have actually worsened economic
conditions 26 percent no effect only 19
of americans in this poll say biden's
policies have improved conditions okay
so this is actually kind of good right
that is the corporate press
acknowledging what we can all see
that something is not right right now
right they're also prepping
their own audience to not accept the
results of the next election i know they
like to say that we are all conspiracy
theorists
right they had four years of trump where
they said he was illegitimate he was a
russian asset facebook somehow installed
him all of the nonsense that they pushed
for four years that's what they said
then the second trump dares question the
election or other people question the
election or dinesh d'souza makes a
documentary about et cetera everyone
else is a conspiracy theorist we should
be banned from twitter kicked off
facebook and everything else but they
are prepping their audience right now
so this is video from msnbc which is a
televised mental institution this is a
woman by the name of tiffany cross don't
know who she is i guess she's a host
over there
and they know see the thing is they know
that right now because of the horrible
biden numbers there is going to be a
crazy red wave but as i always say you
can't get too excited about that or you
can't be too overconfident because god
knows what they could do right before we
get coveted two we get monkey pox eight
they you know russia drops a nuke they
could just do anything right like so you
can't get too overconfident but they're
prepping their audience to not accept
the results of the election because they
really do fear that there's going to be
a red wave and it'll be okay when they
question the results take a look
bombshell new reporting from political
detailing just how deep the republican
plot goes when it comes to trying to
subvert the midterms this november and
of course the general election in 2024.
now according to the recordings of
republican party operatives this was
obtained by politico their plan includes
a multi-pronged strategy this plan to
subvert the election should not come as
a surprise they've been telling us since
they lost in 2020 they know their
policies are trash they know they can't
win election on the merits so it sure
looks like at this point they're going
to cheat because they're telling us
they're going to cheat to make sure they
win
instead it's an absolute mental
institution up there but do you see what
they're doing they're prepping their
people they're prepping them to not
accept the results of the election in
case they don't get the results that
they want they don't they're she's
saying their policies are trash okay how
are the policies of the biden
administration going when it comes to
say foreign policy when it comes to
economic policy when it comes to
literally anything
literally anything how are those things
going not well lady
but this is what they're doing so just i
show you that just to be aware of the
tricks right if we know their full bag
of tricks we'll be able to fight back
you